so hello everyone I'm Kristen desero I'm
the chief learning officer at KH Academy
and I'm going to uh let our two other
panelists do quick introductions of
themselves and then we'll get into
discussions Chris you want to start
first sure I'm Chris Hegel I'm the
executive director of digital learning
for the peninsula School District in Gig
Harbor we're a a school district of
about 9,000 kids we're about 45 minutes
south of Seattle um we kind of jumped in
head first last year
um with AI back in January of last year
um after
seeing quickly the impacts that it could
have for some of our teachers and some
of our students and so um happy to share
anything about that or where we're going
or what we've been doing so
awesome
bobc yeah sure hey everybody I'm bobc
moimi I'm an assistant superintendent
with gwet County Public Schools um we're
the 12th largest school system in the
country so about 180,000 kids um just
north of Atlanta um and we've been on
the AI Journey since December of 2017
actually um and have built out our own
sort of learning framework and three
course pathway uh and really looking at
embedding it for for every kid um
although we're starting obviously with a
with a K12 pilot in one of our sort of
feeders of schools which is about 7,000
students um so really glad to be here uh
today and to be part of this
conversation great thank you so much
I really appreciate the the quick
overview of where you are um Chris could
you tell me a little bit more about what
you've done in your district and maybe
how that relates to some of the
principles sure um we last year our kind
of our technology department our
teaching and learning we were merged
together um we actually did that about
four years ago um into the department of
learning and Innovation and so when
Chachi BT came out we'd been doing some
small
like little Pilots around um AI with
things like the SD Explorations course
or some other um just small learnings
with some small cohorts of teachers six
to 10 teachers um for the last couple
years um but when chbt came out we
really decided oh boy we better we
better do something about this um you
know my technology engineers were
sitting right next to our like teaching
and learning Specialists um and having
these conversations back in in December
last year saying oh boy we better get to
work on doing something um and so we met
with our all of our high school English
teachers in early January last year and
you know of course there was some
anticipated freaking out um a little bit
you know oh my God what are we going to
do but we'd we'd been focusing for the
last few years on implementing Universal
Design for Learning in all of our
classrooms and so teachers were already
having you know doing the thinking
behind I need to change my lessons I
need to change my instruction anyway and
so this just catapulted them to do it
quickly um and so they were able to our
English teachers to their credit were
able to you know kind of pivot even in
that first meeting saying all right well
there's some things that I really didn't
I knew I shouldn't probably be teaching
and doing this this way um I'm just
going to move on this is the this is the
thing that's going to make me move on
from that right now and so um that's how
we started we put together a team of
about 30 teachers where we have about
600 total and our district um but we put
together a team of about 30 teachers um
we called it AI action research last
year um they started experimenting with
different tools different techniques um
working with their kids all of their
kids using different a generative AI
tools um just to kind of understand what
how kids understood what they were doing
or what did kids know just to kind of
collect data and that allowed us to
um build out what what do we believe as
a district what are our principles
around Ai and our beliefs and so that's
how we've kind of gotten to where we are
this year where we're fully embracing AI
in our classrooms um of course not every
teacher is there yet but it's growing
day by day but um yeah that's how we
kind of got to where we are right now
great can you tell me what fully
embracing AI in your classrooms looks
like like give us an example of what
that might be um like I said it's not
every teacher but um you know we we just
recently invited the public into um two
of our middle schools to for American
Education week and what we did is we
focus we brought together teachers from
all over the district and they talked
about what they're doing in the
classroom um with AI and so it kind of
just depends on the subject um we had a
really amazing resource teacher who is
using AI to provide grade level content
to students who may not be able to read
at that level so um she was for giving
me an example or giving the public an
example of how she asks kids to take she
I think she was teaching in 11th grade
um history course at the time and it was
a Supreme Court case that they were
talking about and the kids some of the
kids in that classroom were reading at a
fourth or fifth grade level and so she
just had them take and use um one of the
generative AI tools to take that case
put it in there summarize it and rewrite
it down to a level for that they
understood and so those kids who may not
have the ability to read at that level
we're still able to get the grade level
content that they were you know that she
was teaching in that class um we've seen
quite a few teachers um with our
emergent multi multilingual students
doing the same thing you know rewrite
this into a language that you understand
into your primary first language um and
it still allows them to get the content
that they are teaching in class and
understand um the first the first
classroom I went into that was testing K
the first girl I talked to the first
question she asked me was can I speak
Swahili and I was like I don't know
let's
see yeah yeah we've had a couple of
Science and Math teachers doing the same
thing you know some of the science
Concepts like in AP Chemistry or ason AP
astronomy in the high schools can get
into some pretty technical terms and
sometimes kids don't understand those
words and so they're using it to kind of
help me restate this or take this
content and explain it to me in language
that I understand so those are some of
the more powerful things that I see
happening in our classrooms right now
yeah great all right uh Jim I see your
hand up I'm gonna go to bbec and then
we'll open it up for questions so I'll
go to Jim's question first but if other
folks have questions you can either type
them into the chat or raise your hand as
well and we'll get you next bobc tell me
a little bit more about how you have
started approaching this in Guinette and
what it looks like now sure so back when
we started was December 2017 so people
thought we were absolutely crazy um and
like because at that point like the
public concept of AI was like Terminator
and that about it um and so at that what
what happened with us was we were
reading some of the new sort of news out
of the McKenzie Global Institute and
other places about how the future of
work was shifting rapidly um and we
realized oh my goodness we better get on
this pretty quickly um given how large
of a system we are and how long it takes
to shift practice um and so we started
looking at AI in ter of two different
ways and remember this was pre sort of
public understanding of generative AI um
we started looking at it from like an
embedded and a discrete model so like
the discret model was the sort of like
three course pathway that we built out
with the state of Georgia um where we're
like okay for kids who want to sort of
Deep dive into AI let's make sure that
we have like a strong deep pathway and
that it's not focused just on the
technology or just on the coding but
also has aspects around like ethics and
creative problem solving and like
applied experiences and user design and
those sorts of things uh to make it so
that the kid can be um sort of ready to
go deeply in that work um at the same
time what we realize is that this AI
learning can't just be a high school
thing um and it can't just be for those
sort of deep divers so we talk about our
swimmers and our snorkelers a whole lot
um with this idea of like everyone is
going to have to work in this world of
AI just like today like you can't be
like I don't do the internet right like
well sorry like one way or the other um
if you're in engaged in sort of modern
society like the internet's going to
either do something to you or you're
going to use it for something right um
and so we really dumped and jumped into
the principles around like the knowledge
building and the balance piece where
we're really promoting AI literacy we're
really doing it across all our subject
areas um and looking at how for example
like in a social studies lesson in um
about like the Civil War um how do you
actually build in some data science
components into that so that kids are
building those skills um in our like
English classes how can you build in
like a coding program as one of the
assignments that a kid could do to show
that they like understood a novel and
those sorts of pieces so the idea would
be that through the accumulation of sort
of the K12 uh experience a kid would get
all those different tools and and
knowledge and those this you know
interactions that they'll need um for it
to build up their sort of ability so
we're essentially sort of piloting this
idea of like content as like the
substrate through which we uh are able
to teach really important skills and
like deep thinking abilities um as
opposed to the content being like the
final outcome and this sort only outcome
um and then on the balance side that
that fourth principle is super important
right of like to your point earlier
Kristen like you can't just like say hey
ai go do for me and then like it takes
over sort of your own agency and those
sorts of things we've really started
thinking about like the generative a AI
outputs as like the the new F right like
that's the new floor now like what's the
human element that comes on top of that
and we mean that not only for kids but
also our teachers right so to your point
like if you're building out a lesson
plan like the F lesson plan is that
first one that's generated that's maybe
60 or 70% of the way there if you have a
great prompt now how do you as the human
in the loop like create that extra 30 40
50% of value uh to make it great for
everybody um so it's been really neat
and we've been really focused on our
students of color our women in young
girls in particular trying to sort of
rewrite the narrative um and thankfully
there is no narrative at least locally
on like who does AI uh so we're like all
right let's like start from scratch at
the beginning uh literally and
figuratively right um and and get people
there awesome thank you Jim go ahead
what's your question thank you um one of
the things that I am worried might be
missing from many of these conversations
that I've been observing is rigorous
analysis of traditional preest post test
against a control group uh to measure
effect sizes and I say this from the
position of producing um a language
learning app for all ages ESL primarily
for pronunciation remediation but as
I've been incorporating large language
models I've been able to cover things
like grammar and uh vocabulary that it
was not my traditional field because
I've been so focused on intelligibility
remediation uh so can you talk a little
bit about how you measure uh the
introduction of AI into a curriculum are
you uh are you and your users uh your
customers are they using pre-test post
test analysis against a control group
for effect sizes or is there a different
way to measure that um the motivation
for this question is I have had
surprising results in both directions
things that I thought would be
extremely uh useful had fallen have
fallen flat and vice versa some things
that I thought weren't going to work had
a huge effect size so I'm fascinated
toar learn more right so I'll talk a
little bit about what we're doing and
then would love uh the two of you to
talk about how you're evaluating uh the
success of these programs so for us uh
when we released in March we had a
couple of partner districts and we did
very much qualitative research we
observed what was happening in
classrooms we did interviews with
teachers and students because everyone
was just trying to figure out how to use
this and in my opinion that's too early
to do your you know randomized control
trial of whether things are working or
not uh this fall we have a a plan where
we want to actually compare students uh
in districts that are already strong Con
Academy users without cono and then
being having students some of those
schools uh or potentially classrooms use
kigo and some who don't uh and then we
can we able to then look at results on
other external assessments to see
whether we see that Improvement but
that's a big ask for us of districts so
here's a little plug if you're a
district that's a strong Con Academy
user and you'd be interested in helping
do some of that kind of evaluation work
um we would love to hear from you so uh
that we can do that in more places and
uh be able to make sure we're we are
getting that kind of evidence uh Chris
BC what are you folks doing it's
interesting that you have this question
because it was just something we were
talking about I was talking with our
director of research and assessment last
week um it was mostly around the fact
that um last week there was a research
paper that came out around um using
large language models W in math
education um and the positivity that
they were seeing in that research paper
around that and so um we haven't done
anything substantial yet as far as pre-
and post utilization um because it's
still we're still figuring it out I
think it's it's still really early for
us and so but yeah it is it is something
to look at and I think there are people
researching it and studying it right now
too from a you know at the University
level or this one was written a lot of
it was written by Microsoft research
so yeah yeah Ju Just to jump in there
quickly as well um we've similar to you
Kristen have been looking mainly at the
sort of qualitative data and feedback
since we haven't been focusing on like a
specific AI tool and its impact and
we've really been thinking about like AI
literacy as a whole and how to get a kid
ready for their future um we've actually
just recently embarked on a on a
partnership where we're really looking
at like how do you measure like the
creative problem solving how do you
measure like the E ethical understanding
and those sorts of pieces in students um
related to these Technologies so in the
interim like our our sort of feedback
has been from teachers talking about
highly engaged students from students uh
having better work outputs that they're
actually creating and like better
understanding and deeper understanding
um I'll give a really quick example we
had like a class where a biology class
where they were looking at research
papers and they had um chat gbd generate
one or two as well and the kids had to
actually like look through it and go hey
like what's right what's wrong about
this like scientific paper um and it
actually got the kids to think way more
deeply than just giving them an already
sort of sort of vetted paper and looking
at it that way um so lots of opportunity
and lots of need still to to look at the
the effect sizes and impacts
well I'm going to use my moderator
privilege and ask you a follow-up
question when you're create those those
three courses that are helping on the
technical side students who are really
interested in the Deep dive did you make
up your own learning objectives for that
or are you using some set of a learning
framework yeah so we we built our own
framework back in 2017 uh that we call
the AI learning framework uh and it
essentially has like six components um
around programming data science math
reasoning creative problem solving
ethics and applied experiences um and
then based on those we have like what we
call a K12 Continuum of learning which
is sort of grade band level what we
think kids are going to need to know and
how to like sort of prepare them for
12th grade with the understanding that
that's going to shift and be revamped
every year um as kids start coming in
more and more ready right um for for
these types of experiences um and so the
cor the three course pathway was built
off of that and we had a lot of friends
um from Google from HP from um you know
Microsoft from um from ug from Georgia
Tech all sorts of people a lot of local
industry that came together alongside
teachers to go okay how are we going to
put this into a course that's usable um
or a set of courses that's usable across
our state um so it's really cool and if
you haven't seen them you can check out
the the standards for those courses on
the um Georgia Department of Education
website they have them posted for
everybody to be able to
use awesome great thanks for sharing
those all right I'm gonna take one more
question Jamie I'm clicking allow to
talk
here great um so I'm really interested
in this AI discussion specifically
around the role of human judgment and
critical thinking I hear it a lot um in
webinars and in sessions around AI that
we have to Center the human perspective
here so I'm carries in a two two-pronged
approach from an AI product perspective
Kristen how do you and your company
think about um the necessary shifts in
pedagogy that are coming due to Ai and
like how do you keep up with that to
ensure that students are pushed to do
that judgment and critical thinking
that's so necessary um especially with
like well you know currently so much of
the curriculum can just be knowledge
based but like how do you look ahead and
get ahead of that and then on the school
and District side I would be really
interested in how um from a curriculum
perspective teaching and learning
perspective you two are thinking about
avoiding this like judgment and critical
thinking being taught in a vacuum and
ensuring it's truly integrated into into
the practice of the
classroom great thanks for your question
I will uh start off with the answer from
from our side so one of the first things
about using artificial intelligence as a
tutor is that it can be wrong and so
part of critical thinking is actually
teaching students not to just accept the
answer from the artificial intelligence
and to think to what are the questions
they should be asking themselves about
whether this is the right answer or not
and how would they go about assessing
whether that's the right answer or not
and so that kind of critical thinking
that I mean that's no different from the
internet when you do a search on the
Internet you may get wrong information
too and we've been really struggling I
think as a as a whole to help uh Society
figure out how to judge information and
to process information and to make their
own be able to think critically about
whether it's right or wrong but I think
AI actually provides us a tool uh for
helping to to do some of that and I was
in a classroom where the teacher
actually made it almost a game to figure
out if the uh if the ai's response was
correct or not and if a student could
spot it being incorrect that was a you
know a big exciting thing that happened
um so I think that's one place as we
think about AI literacy that uh brings
in then helping to uh help teach some of
those those critical thinking skills as
students evaluate
information bbec you want to go next for
thinking about critical thinking
yeah I'll jump in and I I'll I'll be uh
really transparent here I know Jamie and
if anybody on this call doesn't know
Jamie you should she's on she's on the
exact opposite side of the continent as
I am but I wanted to put that plug out
there and I think her question is
fantastic so so for us we really think
about the critical thinking and the
Judgment pieces starting in kindergarten
right and it starts off as like easy as
like hey two people might have
completely different opinions about
something and that's okay um and like
here's how to like talk through that
here's how to understand it that then
gets translated ultimately like later on
in their careers into like hey your
lived experiences cause you to have
certain perceptions and biases and like
ways of thinking about decisions but
there are other ways of making decisions
as well right and then we eventually get
to the place of like hey these human
biases can actually show up in the data
sets that are behind a lot of these
algorithms that are that are pumping out
the results uh whether it's generative
or not um in terms of the I um so then
then what happens essentially is within
like math classes for example our
conversation is less around like you
know a random data sets that you're that
you're trying to plot and more of like
hey before we get there where did this
data come from um could it be inaccurate
like what could it be potentially
biasing us towards and those sorts of
things so those sorts of conversations
happen across the curriculum trying to
get kids to to realize that hey there
could be many philosophical perspectives
to something like how do we and
empathize the other side um so that we
can see what they're thinking and why um
and then sort of building that all the
way through so within every class
classroom there's space for judgment
there's space for critical thinking I
and in fact that's really the most
important thing uh because if you can
just like get the answer from chat gbt
or Bard uh then that really wasn't deep
or critical thinking that was just a
sort of fancy regurgitation um and
that's been a really really hard move uh
and pivot for for us to make as a as an
organization as teachers as as all those
things great Chris yeah I'll also Chim
in um we were I was just having this
discussion with a teacher team um from
one of our high schools last week or the
week before um and they had started
moving to
um you're encouraged to use some of
these AI tools but I want to see the
entire conversation so like with some of
them now you can share the link to the
conversation you had so they're looking
more at the thought process and the
thinking that went into the questions
that they asked and not as much onto the
actual output that they generated and so
I think that's a fascinating shift for
the teachers to be able to just see okay
I can kind of understand where you're
going now and I understand I can see
that you know what you're talking about
or you're maybe you're struggling in
this area um and thinking about that a
little bit and so I thought that was a
really interesting way to kind of flip
the way that they're looking at you know
what kids are learning um is to just
kind of watch the actual thinking
process and the thought process to get
to where they got to so I see a couple
of their hands we don't have time for
more questions at this point I do want
to highlight going back to if we think
about what those principles are um that
this was very much aligned to that first
one what are our educational goals to
create critical thinkers all right how
do we use AI to help achieve that goal
um so keep these in mind I do find them
helpful to drive some of the
conversation that we're having let me
offer our panelists the last word uh if
you were going to uh just provide some
advice for folks that are starting out
in their districts trying to Wrangle uh
the artificial intelligence and think
about what they should do what's the
first step they should
take Chris go ahead I get this question
feels like daily now just call ask or
you I did a presentation at the
conference yesterday um
a lot of people are getting hung up on
we need to write policies we need all of
these things in place we need somebody
to tell us what to do and I would just
say you've got to just get started just
try something um there are you know the
TJ toolkit is amazing it has a ton of
work in there um there's some other
stuff put out by Council of great City
schools and Coen um look at those steel
ours like that's what I tell a lot of
people just take the one off our website
and use that to start um that we've
developed in our district so like just
get started get something you know it
doesn't have to be you don't have to get
into this big formal process yet just
get your teachers moving uh if you don't
know where to get started just try it
and get going and then you'll you'll be
able to learn and adapt and adjust from
there yeah I'll jump in I I agree with
that completely and i' I'd actually go
back to the why um and I think if our
entire point in public education or any
education is to prepare kids for their
future our kindergarteners today aren't
graduate until about 2036 which means
that our kindergarten classrooms today
should be preparing them with the skills
and the belief systems and the knowledge
and the mindsets and things that they'll
need to be uh prepared in 2036 and what
that really means is that all of us have
to admit that we don't know much um and
that that's okay we can learn this work
together uh we can do the AI literacy
work and learn ourselves while our kids
are learning as well um and make that
push forward um and similarly to to
Chris find a framework that you're
interested in in and then just start
there and then tweak it for your local
conditions and what people know and and
what people think and believe um you
know I think communities are at a place
where they're recognizing how important
these tools will be in the future uh so
the more we can make sure to prepare our
kids the better off we'll be great thank
you so much both for being here today
and for the just Trail blazing work
you're doing on this stuff and and
sharing it with all of us so thank you
very much thanks to those in uh who came
and and participated today please do as
as Chris and bobc said they have
materials out there on their websites T
AI has plenty of materials I would Echo
just get started just do something and
uh and it's better than kind of the
inertia just getting over that inertia
to do something um I think starts you
moving in the right direction so thank
you everyone we appreciate your time
today and good luck with your AI work
and moving forward